foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
that is
you know
[Music]
many times
[Laughter]
[Music]
good job
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's up
foreign
[Laughter]
come on
[Music]
foreign
the three Muslims we're joined here with
Lord bear from Scotland how's it going
thank you very much for having me on
it's a pleasure
I know how you doing bro
it's always a pleasure to host on her as
well you're looking natural in your
element with the iPhone
I don't know we can expect a little bit
of a professional upgrade in the days to
come isn't that right
inshallah
so brother Lord bear
what is the story behind your name
so a couple people have asked regarding
the Lord bear name and I understand that
a recent revert coming in with something
like Lord in his name can sort of ring
the jail Bells but it's because in in
Scotland in the UK if you own land
you're a landlord it's like a lord lady
thing so it's kind of been a nickname
I've had for a while and it never
crossed my mind until people pointed out
the whole Lord part of it so I probably
will change in the future just out of
respect and I don't it's it's not a hill
I'd like to die on you know and I
totally get why some people might be
concerned where a new revert comes along
gets a lot of attention and goes by the
name Lord you know it can be about red
foggy so I'll probably change it in the
future but it has no ill intentions it's
just like a lord lady status it was an
old meme amongst my old friends for a
while and I never considered it until it
was pointed out so in the future I'll
probably change it I think that was the
the question all the salafis were
wondering so I'm glad that you you
addressed within the first minute also
before we even go into it
me and ano have no idea bro about your
story to an extent compared to around me
because Rami was there in the first
stream that he did with you guys unlike
me and anho who were just joining today
so this will be almost refreshing for me
and him just as much as it is it as it
is to the viewers uh but before we do
get into that
do you want to tell us your real name or
is that confidential my real name is uh
is Matthew Hutcherson and I'll give my
full name because uh I have a disdain
for uh like 99 of my comments are very
positive but there's always Anonymous
characters who will criticize and give
you hate and one of the things that
always annoys me is the fact they remain
anonymous and I think if you don't put
your name to your word it's probably
because your word has ill intentions
behind it so I'm perfectly perfectly
comfortable with sharing my name um
Matthew Hodgson from Scotland 21 years
old I have a backup what I say so we can
go go by Matthew today if you'd like
homely love Matthew I like that I'm just
gonna call you Matthew bro yeah enough
of the comments about Lord but because I
want to address you with your proper
title yeah yeah that's fine my mind I
totally understand it as well and that's
again
um ironically when people point that out
I don't get annoyed by it in fact I like
it
because it shows the uh the carer that
people have for keeping Islam pure
and I say this quite a lot that I think
there's going to be in the future a lot
of influencers who revert but the reason
they Revere isn't perhaps what they say
and it might be to become an idol that
people will follow and lead them in a
straight path so when people point out
little things like this that I perhaps
hadn't have noticed I like it because it
shows that people still care you know
so I probably will change it in the
future
um so yeah inshallah
got you perfect inshallah Grant you a
lot of Baraka in your journey of using
this influence
okay so this being said let's go right
into your story we got a lot to talk
about today your journey as a Muslim
thus far in Scotland we want to talk
about Tate's war room that you're a part
of and some other things like that so
why don't you give in a nutshell your
Reverb Journey thus far yeah so I'll
give you a brief overview because I've
mentioned a lot a lot of it previously
and there's a few new reasons that um I
hadn't noticed until recently and I like
to use the term blinded by sin and it
seems as the longer I go with Islam
and the more Halal lifestyle I live
while cutting Haram it's like the veil
of that past life is being lifted and
you start to see in retrospect why you
chose Islam but to be honest with you it
was an obvious decision
I grew up in the west and I know a lot
of the viewers are from there but I'd
say the majority or maybe Middle Eastern
and the West is so unbelievably
disgusting and I never signed off on it
and I don't understand I don't want to
say I'm different than anyone else
because I think we are all the same
but everyone around me was perfectly
fine with accepting all the Haram that
the West has kind of been
plagued by
and I never enjoyed it even even like
for my example if you take a look at the
in terms of male female relationships
rewarded in the west now it's completely
degeneracy you know
and I I never lacked when it came to
that you know so I expressed all my
desires Etc but even as a guy who who
could take advantage of that I never
enjoyed it you know and there was always
some part in the back of my head that
was going this is completely wrong
and um initially I looked at
Christianity
I had a joke when I was cutting in
because I thought the other gent was
going to be here and my joke was going
to be which one of you is the Holy
Spirit the father and the son but he's
not here so unfortunately I can't do it
but I looked into Christianity and the
the problems with Christianity nowadays
and I don't want to get too deep into
that and because I don't want people
like David wood spamming my email asking
me to come on but um yeah looked into
Christianity didn't make a terrific
amount of sense to me with the amount of
translations of the Bible the amount of
um rewriting of the Bible the amount of
different interpretations that made no
sense like I always say the word Trinity
is never mentioned once the word
Christians never mentioned once the word
bible is never mentioned once
Jesus spoke an americ and if you
translate God in America it comes out to
be Allah
and you look at how Christians used to
pray back in the days of his head on the
ground
so it didn't make a terrific amount of
sense to me and I think just because
um the War Room had a big influence on
it you know because I felt like I was
sort of screaming in a vacuum to a
degree and you'll know that song help
because this is how a lot of your
contents regarding this but you'll see
things like and I always bang on about
this but the fact that um and this has
kind of become a meme because I say it
so much but the fact that pornography is
completely legal for kids to consume and
no one seems to care
and I'm not signing off on that you know
what I mean
and then it was kind of like a process
of reverse engineering
and I was thinking okay
so the people who are trying to give my
children smart on the internet put my
daughters sisters and wives and only
fans put me in debt send me to war
they're also the same people who are
telling me that Islam is bad and in my
head obviously there was a logic feel
and I went well the enemy of my enemy is
most likely my friend you know so I
started to look into Islam and I
realized they were the only ones that
were fighting the things that I wasn't
signing off on if you look at things
like Reba fiat currency
the LG TV agenda the destruction of the
family unit
the only people that were fighting that
and and to a really big degree with all
the wars you've seen was Islam and then
when I started reading the Quran it made
total sense when you start looking into
the life of the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him he's like the archetypal
individual and there's not any of that
propaganda that is associated with how
people interpret Jesus and his teachings
and I always say that once I read the
Quran I started going to mosques and I
uh
started hanging around with more Muslims
I would have seen myself as a liar if I
didn't accept Islam because the truth
hits you in the face you know and if you
if I refuse that I would have seen
myself as a liar and I have an
interesting take on lying I think when
you lie to other people you lie to
yourself when you hurt other people
you're hurting yourself when you molest
someone you're molesting yourself you
know all these things like everything
you project out onto the world actually
comes back to you so it was a very
obvious choice once I looked into it
taking the facts and it was obvious this
day as well because the amount of
propaganda that was being hit
uh with Islam in the west like 7-Eleven
and stuff like that when you look into
that it just crumbles apart and
that's why they required so much
propaganda to demonize Islam because you
couldn't still make them an enemy
because there's nothing
there's nothing bad in the Quran there's
nothing bad about Sharia law this is why
all this propaganda was required so when
it hit me in the face if I didn't accept
it I would have seen myself as a liar
you know so it was a very obvious choice
once it came to me
hmm
a couple other things actually
the two things that I realized today
that I haven't mentioned before
and I've got them here
as uh let me see yeah so the community
is a big part of it and I know you you
guys will feel the same but the amount
of Haram that's currently plaguing the
world and this is the hard part because
resisting Haram can be easy
the problem nowadays is like you don't
even get a chance like when you're a
young guy
soon as you're nine and you have access
to the internet you're exposed to things
that
99.99 of the population were never
exposed to
uh all the culture pushing you in a
certain direction is going to push you
into a world of debt and sin and
heartbreak
and everyone around you is engaging in
it so it seems like there's no light at
the end of the tunnel and and looking
and I don't know how you guys did this
because when I get a comment under my
YouTube I've actually stopped looking at
my comment section
if I get a comment under my channel it's
like you don't know Jesus was God you're
going to hell it infuriates me and to
think the amount of um abuse that that
Muslims got over the past 20 years or so
for things that were so like looking
back on them like the 7-Eleven thinking
stuff it's so ridiculous when you
actually look into it
and to see all the abuse and
infliction that was was brought upon the
Muslim Community the fact that you guys
stayed strong and didn't retaliate in an
aggressive way
stayed strong with your Dean if there's
a group of men
or group of people that I would want to
you know Brothers in Arms fight together
to kind of bring back something like a
Sharia take out a lot of these Haram
institutions it would be Muslims who
else is doing it look at look at America
it used to be a Christian Nation your
entire Financial system is based on
usury divorce rate is 60 the average
young girl in America now has a life
which is in essence the same as a
Victorian prostitute but she's not paid
for it until she gets the 20 and she's
told to go on only fans they aren't
doing anything the only people that
stood up to it were Islam
another interesting one as well like
this is one that just hit me today that
I realized as I'm living that more Halal
life and I'm cutting out the Haram
and you can see this happen with Andrew
Tate as well where you get these um
these guys that have ambition and I
think they do this in war
where and obviously when you look at the
wars in the Middle East it's all before
the war there was no LG TV and there was
no Central Banking and if you look at
Libya Afghanistan Iraq Iran
um Vietnam all these places Had State
banking where a gold back currency prior
to the war and after at the ad Central
Banking which is how you can bring in
things like the corn and the corn
industry because you can just print
money to keep it running
and I I think another ulterior motive
behind that is you take the alpha males
of a nation that would have gone on to
create families create communities stand
up in the face of sin and Haram being
inflicted on their population and you
send them to a foreign Nation to die and
if you look at Andrew Tate's story he's
an ambitious guy and I resonate with
them quite a lot and I think that's how
I've managed to get into spheres like
the war room and do quite well for
myself at a young age
the the culture that's
pushed on young men who have ambition
if you've got the idols like people like
Drake they take young men who would have
gone on to do these things and they give
them this lifestyle where they take that
energy they take that passion they take
that commitment
and they try and make you
do Haram so if you look at Andrew Tate
for example he has the potential to
shift the world and what he's doing now
is fantastic I mean he's a big part of
the reason why I refer to Islam but
prior to Islam what was he using his
powers to do after kickboxing casinos
nightclubs
um putting girls on webcam and I noticed
this very quickly with me like last year
I had a few ideas that I would never act
upon now and to see
Sharia you read what is Haram you read
the life of the Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him
um your whole view on the world changes
so now the things I'm doing is I'm
making the social media that has no
Haram on it so when kids go on it
they're not going to be hit with
propaganda there's going to be no nudity
no Haram music no false Idols if I
didn't have Islam what would I be using
that that energy to do I might have put
girls on only fans I might have ran
casinos you know and if you look at what
Andrew's doing now I know he's
completely stopping all that he's coming
out the casino industry
so to find Islam at such a young age as
well that stops me from taking that
potential I have and putting it down an
Avenue which is Haram you know so that
hit me today but it was a very obvious
choice overall I it's only been a month
and a half and I say this to people very
frequently now that I couldn't imagine a
life without it I don't see another way
of life that bears any fruits you know
like I even if you're a guy that has
ambition drive you know right and wrong
I don't see a way of life outside of
Islam that bears any fruits to any
degree and I I couldn't comprehend the
life without it you know even when it
comes to marriage and things what would
my alternative have been in the west you
get some woman that's been ran through
by 50 different guys who has a Snapchat
and Instagram account wherever you
question why she's doing that you get
gaslit into Oblivion and you get
divorced lose half your stuff
like I don't understand the life outside
Islam you know and it's only been a
month and a half which is great so I'm
looking forward to seeing how things go
in three months or six months or a year
you know so so yeah martial arts is
fantastic I feel very blessed to have uh
came to this conclusion at such a young
age you know
um I guarantee you bro the last 20 years
it seemed like a blur like you can't
imagine life without Islam No
you can't imagine it I just don't see a
way of life that would bear any fruits
at all look at Jeff Bezos for example
Jeff bezel's the most rich guy in the
planet he created the second rich woman
in the planet like even if you're a
hyper successful hyper-competent guy
your life in the west without this
strong structure of living this moral
Foundation it's just going to crumble
you know and I think a lot of the the
purpose I'm gonna have is I kind of feel
like and I use this analogy a lot that I
kind of feel like to a degree I'm like a
Warner
so I feel like and there's one Castle
there's one Fortress which is Islam and
then there's this
satanic LG TV Haram sinful way of life
like this massive
um
cabal and I feel like I was kind of
roaming in the woods not knowing what I
was doing and then I came to Islam but
I've seen the marching Army in the
distance you know so when I see things
and you guys will know this as well that
there seems to be like a watering down
of Islam and I think my rule
in in this life anyway will be to ensure
that people do not compromise their Deen
because when you start giving shatan an
inch you really give them a mile if
women start taking off their hijabs
where does it stop if you take off your
hijab why wouldn't you start posting
provocative things on Instagram and what
are the fruits of that well I've
experienced it so I think my role is
going to be
warning people about that to a degree
and I've seen a few things which uh
either had to keep my mouth shut to a
degree I'm not going to name names but
I've seen something the other day and I
know this is more of a Shia thing I've
spoke to people about it and I don't
want to this has nothing to do with you
guys but it's just how I interpret
things but I've seen things like no
strings in the car
and I think people nowadays may be
inclined to accept that and I've seen
that the other day and as a guy who's
experience where that goes I'm not you
can't accept things like that so if
that's what that's what I can bring to
the table or these new ideas are brought
in like temporary marriages in essence
just to fornicate it's just pretty much
fornication you get married you
you do the deed and then get divorced
again if you accept that where do you
draw the line you know so inshallah if I
can sacrifice enough I'll be able to
stop these things from infiltrating
Islam because I've seen it and it annoys
me because I don't think people know
where that goes you know it goes to a
very dark place and not those shallow
and temporary Pleasures that you get
from that in the long run it's never
worth it you know it's never worth it so
so yeah crazy that we need a 20 year old
Reaver from Scotland bro to tell us
common sense about what's right and
wrong in the in the theme and I thought
it was a flight towards you bro but just
a lot of people today thinking things
like no strings in the car or temporary
marriage and things like that are okay
I don't I don't understand how 1400
years of no-nonsense all of a sudden we
think that this is okay but if you
really study Islam and you study
you know better or Innovations and
things that are not permissible they're
nothing new Bro they've been doing
temporary marriages since 13 1200 years
ago even before Islam this is something
outside of Islam Islam came to end that
but
non-muslim secular ideology will always
bleed into Islam that's why you will
always find Muslims kind of co-signing
these things sooner or later
mm-hmm well what I would say to that is
I would say it's a very different world
nowadays and I think you're going to
face challenges like not like not
previously
um because of the internet and I came to
a realization the other day and I want
to bring this up again because I know
this is going to get a lot of views and
I think it's important and I don't think
people have heard this before and I
think this is going to open people's
eyes this is why I'm working very hard
to create a Halal social media so there
is a theory it's not a theory it's been
proven in 2018
something changed on the internet where
more fake bought accounts surpass the
amount of number of real accounts on the
internet
and nowadays I believe when you look
into it for every real account on the
internet there are nine fake accounts
and they're not incompetent accounts
like people can buy followers if you
look at chat gbt the AI algorithms you
wouldn't be able to distinct between
real and fake you know
so say for example you wanted to
normalize something like temporary
marriages which I don't understand how
that's permissible in any form at all
because what is the point of a marriage
the point of a marriage is to stop men
and look we can look we can all admit
this like of course guys we have the
instinct to
to sleep with women Etc but the whole
point of a marriage in my eyes is to
ensure that that the woman is cared for
and protected and that the child has a
father in the house so what is the point
if you're just going to get divorced
after it the point
and this is very important for people
watching so I want you to listen to this
clearly
um
I see this a lot so for example if you
wanted to get people to be normalized
with things like temporary marriages or
you wanted to normalize things like
women taking off their hijab you wanted
to normalize men being more like alcohol
and things
what you can do nowadays and people
don't know this but I've looked into it
and I see how it works and again with
these platforms like Instagram Facebook
Tick Tock Twitter they're free and
they're free for a reason because you
are on the product I'm launching my own
social media I understand how much these
servers would cost if you want to tell
me that ad revenue is what's keeping
that up you're completely wrong
so what will happen is say you take a
video and I've seen this the other day
and this is what brought this to my
attention it was a young woman and a
hijab
and the video was something along the
lines of or I'm sticking to my Dean but
I really want to go out clubbing with
girls and have fun
if you pump that video up to 900 000
likes on an account with a million
followers and again you don't know the
difference between real and fake
accounts right these things are free for
a reason because your mind is the
product and again with fiat currency
they don't need your money because they
print money so when people think it's
Financial it's not they print the money
pump that full of likes you go into the
comment sections and then you fill it
with a bunch of female bot accounts
saying this is what I want to do this is
what I want to do what happens then a
real young Muslim girl goes into it and
she sees oh
all the young Muslim girls my age like
it I might as well do it they see it as
the norm now because you know women tend
to just fall this is how back in the day
if there was a tribe that was being
conquered by another tribe the woman
would instantly have to just belong to
the the new tribe you see this in war
where um a country will get bombed and
then the woman end up marrying the men
that bombed their husband because they
have to survive
so this young girl goes on to and she
sees oh yeah look at all these accounts
these are real people you know it's got
loads of Lights people like it yeah men
are oppressive I should take my hijab
off all this sort of stuff you're going
to see that because I've seen it in the
West you see Paul snow with these
accounts again no one knows who runs
them and I always use this the term body
count name me the person who came up
with the term body count you can't where
did that come from no one coined the
term body count and just got
into the stratosphere not everyone used
it so a term which degrades a living
human being to nothing more than a
vessel for your lust has become the norm
name the person that coined that term
you can't it's inorganic so now I'm
seeing things where they turn the first
thing you do instead of dropping bombs
on people as you turn the man against
the woman because that breaks the family
so if you can get an account with a lot
of followers Pump It full of likes and
pump it full of comments that agree with
videos like where guys will say Muslim
girls want to get married but blah blah
blah blah or an account for Muslim women
will say when the guy wants to marry you
but he can't afford a house blah blah
blah blah pump the comments full of
things that are agreeing with it now
you've got the men and women arguing
this is inorganic it's not real these
accounts are not real again why are
these things free so now you've created
a fake culture that people believe are
real that is real when it's not when
people when real people go into these
posts they think oh yeah the women are
my enemy the the men think the women of
their enemy the woman take the man of
their enemy is inorganic it's not real
so
um with regards to things like that the
internet is changing the game so when I
see things like no strings in the car
there is a part of me that is uh
of course you don't want to overstep
your boundaries but you have to stay
strong with this sort of stuff
because this is what's going to be
normalized this is what's going to be
fed to young people
I think once diagram which is the social
media I'm making goes up that'll change
the game because you can't do that and
guardrons is wild run I like that I mod
it and if you do that you're banned
um but again these things when things
are free why are they free because
you're the product and I use the analogy
over and over again I'll use it again
here because it's very important if a
farmer wants to milk an animal if it
wants to milk a goat if the farmer wants
the milk a goal it can't because the
goat will kick back the goat will run
away it'll get aggressive you can so
what do you do you give the goat feed
you give something it wants and then it
comes over it eats the feed and you can
milk it Twitter feed Instagram feed
Facebook feed YouTube feed these things
are free because you are the product why
do you think pornography is completely
legal and free
do you think that's making a profit with
35 of all the traffic on the internet
going to pornography day in and day out
do you think that's an industry that can
be sustained for free I don't think so
but if you have fiat currency you can
print and print and print and print keep
it open again and Sharia law that's
illegal
so when these things are free there you
are the product and I I was speaking to
a gentleman with regards to Morocco
because I'm thinking of moving to
Morocco perhaps the end of the year and
it's starting to get inflicted with this
Pro a b o r t i o n and LG TV agenda
and they always use it under the guise
of Freedom they say you're free to do
this woman should be free to take the
hijab off when they come at you with
these freedoms it's feed that they give
cattle to Mellow you out so they can
conquer you and all these things and
this is for the woman watching this so
listen listen carefully because they're
going to attack you because you're more
emotional don't get angry at me it's
just the the way it is
um
what are you free to do all the freedoms
they give you are things you could do in
a six foot jail cell so you're not free
to buy a house without Reba because
they're 400k because they've been
artificially pumped up through the roof
because companies like BlackRock can
take money from the Federal Reserve buy
them all up and shoot the price of
assets through the roof you're not free
to live off your own land but what are
you free to do murder your Offspring you
think that's empowering you're free to
fornicate with people that don't love
you you're free to take your hijab off
so lustful men can degrade you to
nothing more than a vessel for their
their passions these are things you
could do in a jail cell so when people
they always use the freedom thing what
they do is they target your empathy and
they give you Freedom so if you look at
the event that occurred recently
and the the snowvid the snowboard 91 uh
because I don't want to get these banned
what did they do they targeted your
empathy you said they said if if you
don't put your gag on then you're
killing your Grant
because then if you question that you
look like a cycle
so what they do is they'll come they'll
come to the Muslim countries and like I
said they'll use these social media
platforms to artificially normalize it
through fake accounts
and they will tell you woman you're free
to take your hijab off and murder your
Offspring you're free to do that in a
jail cell what are you not for you to do
raise a family with a rebar you know
question these things because when they
give you nice things that you think that
you're going to enjoy they're not doing
it because they care about you they
would happily send you to
the the yellow and blue country that's
at war with the other country in Eastern
Europe they don't care about you they're
giving you these things because they're
feed and they want to extract from you
so be careful because the things they
say the things they're promoting to you
under the guise of freedoms are not what
you think they are they are not freedoms
they're chains to enslave you with and I
always use the the saying that shaitan
can't do anything to you he can't strike
you with lightning they always have to
make you want to do it to yourself if
you look at the wars that occurred
between the west and Muslim countries
they can't just put a gun to your head
and send you to war they have to make
you want to do it so it'll create events
like 7-Eleven was an inside job
so then you want to do it to yourself so
the onus of sin is on you if you look at
the the Zion
um it is real
um
they can't make you watch the pornos
they can't put a gun to your head and
force you to do it they can't force you
to murder your Offspring they can't
force you to compromise your deem they
have to make you want to do it so they
always Target your empathy or or Market
it to you under the guise of freedom
so when you see these things being
promoted in Muslim places like no
strings in the car where all women if
she's alone because I've seen the guy I
kind of want to call him over I'm not
gonna because I might regret it but it's
always sold under the guise of oh a
woman doesn't want to get married and
she just wants to have fun no no no it's
the freedom thing again you know and
these are the chains that will enslave
you you can't accept and be very
cautious of that because I've seen the
fruits of that rotten tree and they're
poisonous so watch out for that because
I can see look at the world now the only
Last Hope is Islam so of course they're
going to try and subvert it and water
them the dean and no one can make you
water during the day no one can make you
compromise your faith you have to do it
to yourself and the way they get you to
do it to yourself is through marketing
emotions targeting empathy selling it
under the guise of Freedom so hopefully
I know that I've said that people can
look at things that they were thinking
or are potentially going to compromise
their Dean on things like alcohol that
are becoming normalized Reba being
normalized I believe in the Quran that
Reba
um Allah said that if you take Reba
you're Waging War against Allah it's a
very as soon as you take Reba you're a
slave and that's being normalized and
again how do they do it they can't make
you take the loan with interest they
have to make you want the Mercedes-Benz
so you can impress the woman that isn't
Halal you know they can't do anything to
you so just watch out because that's how
they're going to get you they can't put
a gun to your head they can't attack
Islam directly but they have to make you
do it to yourself you know
so crazy bro
I read a book recently called the other
persuasion and in the book the writer
was talking about how we as humans were
very emotional creatures
and uh when you're trying to get your
way with something instead of
uh like fighting your way through it's
just a matter of
appealing the other person's emotions
and making them feel like you know what
we're both doing this together so it's
in our best interests so they feel good
to help you or to do the thing that you
want them to do
and then now it's like I'm linking that
with what you're saying and
it's truly like there's nothing logical
about this
no you said someone's gonna get if I
offer you a loan I'm like yo bro I'm
gonna give you ten thousand dollars but
you have to pay me back like
four or 5K extra just because because
I'm giving this up front you'll be like
nah bro I'm good but if I if I'm
appealing to your your emotions if a
part of you wants to get this new car
let's say it's a Mercedes ball yeah
you're loving the way it looks and you
want it so bad bro maybe it's like a
childhood dream of yours
and I'm telling you bro like you have
never had this car
it's there man you can have it right now
you just need the money and you tell me
bro but I don't have the money bro I can
get you all the money that you need but
here's a here's a drawback
are you gonna buy it off your emotions
but you're gonna take the thing off your
emotions so it's crazy that you're
saying that and that I never actually
thought about it
but this whole feed thing
it all makes sense why is it free
because I'm currently running the
numbers and how much it's gonna cost
so if diagram gets a million users which
I think inshallah and oh reality check I
think it will probably in the next few
years reach 100 million users because
there's nothing like it the bandwidth
that the money that costs to run without
the app crashing I know that these
companies aren't staying afloat with
just ad Revenue
they're free for a reason and with
regards to rebound I'm gonna bring it up
again and I may be won't get bored of me
bringing this up but it's so incredibly
important everything starts with a rebok
because if you so I I'll break it down
say us three
were on an island or say the other jet
was here so there was four of us and we
were on an island
and we were trading skill for skill say
um Angel you were a plumber and I was a
farmer you would fix my toilet and I
would give you wheat exchange service
for service then a gentleman who
typically comes from a certain region of
the world
um and it is very it is real
if you see where I'm going
um he will come on a boat and he will
have a barrel full of gold there is no
gold but he'll tell you there's gold
and he'll say to us for I'm gonna give
you a receipt a note in exchange for
this gold that I have in my Barrel if
you take this it's a thousand dollars
because that's all a dollar used to be a
dollar used to be a receipt for gold
that was in the bank now there's no gold
so it's kind of like coat hangers if you
go into like a club or a bar everyone
gets a coat hanger for their jacket well
there's no coats left and everyone has a
coat hanger and this is why these wars
occur because people want to go back and
get their coat there's no coat so the
America bombs them pretty much
um so we take it a thousand dollars each
he says we can build more infrastructure
we can trade overseas we'll have a
growth in our productivity all I ask you
to do is give me back six percent APR
well let me tell you if you only have a
thousand dollars in your economy and
you've got to pay back a thousand and
sixty you can't and now you're a slave
and you see this slowly as time goes on
because if you look at Sharia law taxes
are not you don't need to taxes taxes
are a farce I'm going to mention this
again I mentioned it a lot do you think
they need the 50 from a guy in London
earning 100K when a house is a million
do you think they need that they don't
they just go print 10 trillion to go
bomb some country overseas because they
won't take LG TV right they don't need
your taxes
1060 and there's only a thousand in the
economy you can and slowly over time
things gets the money gets sucked out
and sucked out and sucked out and sucked
out look now no one owns their house no
one owns their car so then when an event
like the um snowboard 91 comes along no
one can defend themselves because they
don't own the assets they are dependent
on
so Reba's a big one and I don't think
and I'm going to mention this as I
always do when you see things like what
we were talking about earlier like the
Social Media stuff like things like the
pornography industry which I will
continue to hammer away at I don't care
how much gaslighting I get for it people
people talk about I'll bring up the fact
that young children are exposed to the
most disgusting things on the planet
when they don't even mean to be exposed
to it and people go you're so obsessed
it's because you can't stop watching it
no I don't like the fact that young kids
are now every single child is being
molested because of what's in their
pocket I don't like that and the fact
that people question me on that Ring's
alarm Bells
when you see things like that being
normalized you can't see it as a minor
inconvenience you have to see it as
bombs dropping from the sky because it
is if you wanted to kill 50 million men
like in World War II it's going to be
expensive you're going to lose a lot of
your population The Man the fighting age
man going into somewhere like America to
bomb it
you're going to get a retaliation from
that Nation or if you wanted to kill 50
million people in War what you could do
give everyone pornography and what
happens then the men become sterile they
become feminized and castrated they
don't procreate because why would they
go seek a a wife when they could get
more women in five minutes than Genghis
Khan got in his entire lifetime while
they're at the age of what 10
then that brings in promiscuity because
the women are unsatisfied you give them
a false idol like cardi B who again was
she an up and coming up and coming Some
Cloud rapper or did she just come out of
nowhere
cycle it along 50 Generations there's
Now 50 million people that haven't been
born because the birth rates drop look
at the West I think the birth rate in
the west is like one point in America is
like 1.4
you need three minimum to sustain the
society because people die of course so
now there's 50 million people that
haven't been born and and then the
people that are still around are so
broken because of the life they've lived
they can't fight
so you can't see it as a minor
Indulgence these things are bombs
dropping from the sky and I can prove it
when you look at um it is real
when they took over the television
stations and um Palace time
what's the first thing they did
they took over three when um when I'm
Massad
and when they took over the television
stations in Palestine what's the first
thing they did they started playing
pornography because it weakens the men
at Cox and castrates the men these
things are not minor indulgences they're
war and it needs to be treated as such
and if it robbed me the people that do
this if I ever had enough influence or
wisdom or power to to bring it down I
wouldn't go lightly on on these things
are war and it can't be treated as any
less as it you know and I can prove that
like you said look at the birth rate you
could have went into America in the 60s
and dropped bombs or you give the baby
boomers nightclubs wheat
um Raves and pornos I know the birth
rate is nothing you know these things
are serious and by the way that's a good
one for the the churchians that sit in
my comment section you know you you bang
on about how Jesus Is God but you
couldn't you know couldn't go to church
when the Beatles came around you know
what I mean and now the West is like
Sodom and Gomorrah so again treat these
things with the utmost severity because
I can see the fruits of it man it's
terrible and uh
yeah crazy
um
yeah 100 it's crazy you know what I mean
um but again no one can make you do it
sorry I'm changing my life no one can
make you do it again they can't put a
gun to your head and go divorce your
wife and go to a Beatles Concert they
have to it's like comic retribution they
always have to make you do it so the
onus of sin is on you you know and like
you said earlier with the reaper thing
what will they do they'll give you a
formicidal like a rapper who's in a
Lamborghini and this is why I wanted I'm
warning is about things like people
infiltrating Islam who will Revere but
they don't actually have the best
intentions and it's to lead people
astray
they'll get a rapper Who's like who
wants to be Drake no one wants to be
Drake I could crush okay no one wants to
be Drake okay
so like I said previously with the
social media thing how do they get
people to want to be like Drake a
sterile fruitcake who complains all the
time acts like a woman is completely
indulgent and materialistic right what
do they do so they'll get they'll get
things like Instagram YouTube they'll
pump the views up on his songs to
hundreds of millions they'll get fake
comments in the comment sections of
girls being like I love Drake I love
Drake and then young men like me and you
go into the comment section we want to
find a wife and we see all these
accounts of women
saying oh yeah Drake he's so hot and
then we tried to emulate him and that's
what's going to happen with Islam and
I'm not saying it's already happened but
it is going to happen in the future
where they get these false idols and the
the they straight people off the path
you know but like with the Reba thing
they can't make you do it they have to
make you idolize some celebrity who
drives a certain car and acts a certain
way like Drake so then you take the Reba
and you enslave yourself they can't make
you do it you have to do it to yourself
you see where I'm coming from
it all works in steps
yeah that's associated yeah it's like um
the you know you know you boil a frog
alive so there's the thing where you put
a frog in a um
and a pan and you turn the temperature
up a degree and a degree and a degree
and a degree and the Frog doesn't know
it's boiling until it just drops dead
because it's slow
and this is how it works man and when
you see little things like no strings in
the car I actually a couple of the War
Room guys who um
keep me in check because I have a
tendency just to go with these things
like I was gonna
um challenge him to fight and everything
and like Muay Thai but I uh rained it in
a bit but when you see these things man
you can't that's the beginning of it and
if you start to accept that where do you
draw the line you know
when you when you separate things like
because you see this now like people
talk about Halal dating
you know how here's one thing right if
you separate marriage and sex
how can you defend yourself against LG
TV because what is the difference
between two men doing sodomy
and a woman and a man
in a marriage procreating is that you
can create family right it's not
inverted if you have two people who are
on birth control and like pulling out
and doing disgusting things you see in
pornos because it's free again why
you're now no different than LG TV
there's a good book that I recommend you
read and I know you'll love this Angel
right it's called a billion Wicked
thoughts and this is why Christianity I
think was conquered it's called a
billion Wicked thoughts and they took
all the search data of Christians in
America
and it's the general it's disgusting but
this is what happens if all the
Christian men are secretly behind closed
doors enjoying the things that they call
sinful how can they then prosecute it in
person they can't because they're doing
it themselves you know
so when things are getting normalized
don't accept it and again they can't
make you do it they can't make you not
like fornicate you have to do it to
yourself and the way they do it is
through marketing so understand that
when they give you things and they'd
sell it to you under the guise of
Freedom Liberation having fun it's to
enslave you you know
you know what I mean
yeah I do know what you mean I think the
first step for many people is to step
away from most social media not that our
the what was it the dawa diagram
no we'll keep that one we'll keep that
one if people want to be on this uh on
social media they can be on dialogram
but I think the first step is for people
to step away from the social media that
is present nowadays
and then they can start to see uh
there's actually strings attached to
everything
and it's almost like there's there's
people in control from behind the scenes
like public messes and I'm not trying to
spin off like any type of a
example that's been given nowadays I'm
just trying to say like there's always
some ulterior motive there's always like
this plan that's going on behind the
scenes and we don't see it until we can
take a step back it's like being so far
up that you you can't see anything
around you but the moment you you pull
away that's when you can see everything
and with these people man when they
start to see that
uh I don't know man I completely lost my
opinions but to be honest with you
but this is why the idea free as well
because it's distracting you know are
you are you this is why I don't like
music personally
because if your head's full of song
lyrics how are you going to remember to
how are you going to remember things you
know so they keep you hyper distracted
as well you know I think do you know
this and I think I'm correct in saying
this so you know the the Federal Reserve
the place that prints all the fiat
currency to go like do all the
disgusting things we were talking about
you know what I want about did you know
the Federal Reserve was passed on
Christmas Eve why because no one cared
because they were distracted with Santa
Claus you know
so they'll keep you distracted so you
don't pay attention things like like I
think music is remarkably nefarious in
my opinion
um and it goes back to what I was saying
about they can't make you do it so let's
let's
um look at different cultures here right
um the the black population in America
in the 50s
civilized everything was great it was
stand by me and let me cry on your
shoulder Christian you know then what
did they do they couldn't go up to that
guy that man who was working hard for
his family in the 50s and go you're
gonna get a gun You're Gonna Leave the
woman like what happens three out of
four times now and you're gonna go join
a gang because they would have said no
so what did they do
here's Jay-Z here's 50 Cent idolize him
now they go to the same words that they
put in these rap lyrics
if they had told that to that guy
without the lyrics without the music
sorry he would have rejected it so they
give you that hypnotic beat so you
accept it look at women if you took a
woman in the West in the 50s a mother
with eight kids and a husband who would
take a bullet for her and you told her
you're gonna leave that guy you're gonna
make an only Fan's account murder your
children while they're in your womb and
then you're go then you're going to get
ran through by strangers in the club
they would have punched you they would
have refused it so what do they do cardi
B
my WAP and then they accept it London
London was what an architectural
beautiful place a Powerhouse in the
world it was completely normal safe
place
so they give you dig a d they give the
drill you get they give you drill music
but you stab this guy stab that guy stab
this guy I know it's the stop capital of
the world if you look at like
um people of my ethnicity like white
people in Europe like Vikings they
couldn't go up to that guy and say
you're gonna be a loser who's
spineless and cowards to mums on
Facebook giving you smack because you
won't put a gag over your face like
we've seen over the past few years so
they'll give you Ed Sheeran my woman is
God I'm a I know every guy in the
west is a you know it's all it's
through the music that they get you the
same
the lyrics in the music if they told
that to you in person you would slap
them in the face so they give you that
hypnotic beat to insert the program
again you know where where is where's
music not allowed in Islam it's Haram
you know so when these things get
normalized don't accept them
because again why is all cardi B's music
free why is cardi B's music all free
when houses are through the roof when
food's full of incarcinogens and you
can't afford to feed your family when
the cost of living is through the roof
why is cardi B's music all free because
you're the product you know yeah yeah
it's programming
it's complete programming and again like
we said they can't make you do it you
have to do it to yourself so they
they'll Hammer you with all these things
just to try and get you to do it but you
can recreate you know like shatan is
below you you can reject them
and this is exactly what I was trying to
get on before before my train of thought
had left me you know inshallah doesn't
leave me again
but once we take a step back and we
start to see that everything
it's not real then we start to see that
these people these Idols that are uh
being made to be these top things where
we're all going to follow them
it's fake it's these rappers it's fake
bro like in Puerto Rico we have so many
of these uh
these reggaeton rappers that are big let
me tell you about the big but when you
actually look into their lives they are
nothing of what they portray the things
they say they do the life they say they
live
none of it is real
and then when you start to see this you
start to ask yourself the question okay
well why are they
making music in this manner it can't
just be to get their ego off
right maybe a little part of it is to
get their ego off but then you start to
get the realization okay it's it's
definitely programming there's
definitely an ulterior motive here
and then it's like we were talking about
the music you listen to music
the moment you start to listen to
something and it is it sounds good you
start to Bob your head the moment you
start to Bob your head or you move your
body in any way shape or form which most
often times you can't even stop yourself
from doing it but the moment you do that
that's it you've already submitted
subconsciously to the music and when you
submitted subconsciously to the music
whatever is being said Within the Music
like we were talking about you are
taking all of that in
whereas before you wouldn't have
accepted anything that they were saying
so I think it's crazy man when we really
boil down to what's really going on
behind the scenes
bedtime this is where I get theological
with things as well so you'll know this
I think you'll probably know a lot about
this about like the subconscious mind
how it works right so I don't
consciously think contract bicep extend
it just happens you know when you're
driving a car you don't really
consciously think anything it's just
like all patterns when you cut open a
human brain this is going to get
interesting I've said this before like
you were talking about you just start
bobbing to it you start bobbing to the
music you know again you don't
consciously think to do it you just
start doing it right cut open a human
brain there's no part of the brain for
the mind there's no part of the brain
for the conscious the subconscious or
imagination
so it's almost like we're an antenna
connected to like a higher power you
know and this is why I always say
inshallah because I really don't know
how many of the thoughts in your head
are actually your own because again
there's no part of the human brain for
the mind the conscious subconscious and
Imagination and people think that's
crazy how are you watching this it's
frequencies through the air and antenna
and you're now watching me in the past
and you're perceiving it as live through
your phone so it's not garbage
when you start bobbing to that music
when you know when when you took that
guy in the 50s I was talking about about
his family and then he's given 50 Cent
music telling them to shoot people and
he starts bobbing whose thoughts are
that in your head
are they your own you know here's a way
I'll put it and I've used this before
you drank alcohol you run a nightclub
you drink
and then you start getting thoughts
coming into your head you don't
consciously think them saying fornicate
with that
gorlock the Destroyer over there the fat
woman I've never done that myself I
never stood down all right but I know
guys do right the whale the whale and
the mini skirt over there it's half two
now yeah it's half tuna you need to get
something
and then the bouncer who's six foot
eight who could kill you if he wanted to
you now want to fight him whose thoughts
are that in your head are they your own
thoughts because you don't logically
discern the whale that's come out of the
ocean and put a mini skirt and makeup on
you want to sleep with her you don't
logically think of it because in the
morning you're disgusted the bouncer who
could batter you you want to fight him
these thoughts just come to you and I
ask whose thoughts are they I don't
think they're your own I think they're
shatan and how did he get into your head
because you gave him consent with
alcohol when you look and I'm gonna
bring this up because I know you
specialize in this when you look at
pornography
um
and you notice when you come off it your
brain rewires and like all the old
things that you used to find attractive
you're like what what is that you know
you're repulsed by it
whose thoughts are in who whose thoughts
are that in your head the things that
that turn you on when you're watching
that stuff compared to when you're not
it's just a response you don't
consciously that like you we look at a
woman we don't consciously Go hip to
waist ratio and chance of you just get
aroused you're just like yeah it just
happens it's a physical response to
stimulation the things that you aroused
by when you engage in Xenon pornography
you don't find them arousing when you're
off them whose arousal is it is it yours
because I don't think it is I think it's
shatan and I think you give him consent
to start planting thoughts in your head
when you engage in this stuff you know
and I think the alcohol one's a Perfect
Analogy as soon as you're done with
drinking you don't want to fight that
bouncer you don't want to sleep with um
the whale but when you're wrong
you don't want to be there I used to
work in a nightclub and I think this is
what put me off them and uh for the
nightclubs look at nightclubs right and
I this came to my attention a week ago
nightclubs are an industry because we
know this if women stopped going to
nightclubs guys wouldn't go no guy wants
to pretend to Bob no guy likes dancing I
don't want to stand there going yeah
yeah let's have fun the only reason guys
go to nightclubs is because women go
right the only way the nightclub
industry can exist and
realize this because I think they're
blinded by their sin and I never
realized it and since I've cut that out
I can see it as clear as day
the nightclub industry can only exist if
you turn Mothers Daughters wives and
sisters into
and that's completely normal now because
like I said guys wouldn't go to
nightclubs if women didn't
so
like these things like they're just I
had a train of thought there and I can't
remember what I was going to say
but yeah you know what I mean you get
right can I quickly up to the toilet by
the way I've been I've been doing a
water
fasting bro please yeah I've been I've
been doing a water fast and everything
I'm drinking is just going I'll be like
two minutes right yeah perfect big
things take time
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
that's me back
uh actually let me set up some lights
here so it's a
little more prop
ER
right well they're gone we're going to
be talking about the Trinity and how
it's really true
let's be honest right
Jesus peace be upon him said forgive
them Father they don't know what they do
he prayed right but he was actually
praying to himself you might think right
now that you're watching three guys on a
podcast
you're not we're all one I am Angel and
he is uh fayad we're all the same so
let's be real now right
you know there's a lot of people that
actually believe this right it's crazy
eh
what a healthy diet as well
I don't know man it's very crazy some
people believe that like I am you and
you are me and that every religion is
correct
do you want me to give you my quick
summary of that
so I've been looking into the um
prophecies that will occur when the the
jail returns right now wouldn't it be
convenient if and a lot of them are
coming true and there was one specific
one which was crazy it was like
the when the when the end times come and
that the general returns women will be
clothed yet unclothed at the same time
and then you look at like leggings and
yoga pants and stuff right and what they
wear nowadays they in essence are naked
wouldn't it be convenient if you were
the the jail returning if you could
convince the second largest religion on
the planet that God could take the form
of man
do you see
if you were the dijal and you wanted to
stray people away from Allah and the
true path it would be convenient when
you were on your way if the second
largest religion on the planet believed
that God could take the form of man you
know
I think that's what it is because it
makes no logical sense to me at all
um and yeah what a hell to die on as
well you know it's just
it all goes back to what we said that
someone else is in control or some
others are in control here because you
see what's going on and we go back to
the thing that we said in the beginning
where we as humans we are emotional
beings we function off emotion and you
when you look at Christians
you give them the logic and it's they
don't accept it they're blind to the
logic just recently there was this one
Christian YouTuber his streamer his name
is a young Don
and and when you first reverted to
Christianity but I'm sure you saw it he
was all about he was real passionate and
you know may Allah bless him for that
passion that he has me Allah guide him
but after a while he started to see
himself
that the Trinity is not real
there is no mention of the Trinity
there's no mentioned once in the Bible
it does not bro it's not mentioned the
Holy Spirit or Jesus peace be upon him
as being the Creator
but it mentions the father as the
Creator many many times within the Bible
so he's seeing that and then by his own
logical deduction
when he speaks what he is finding he
starts being castrated for it he starts
being put down uh did I say cancel bro
just because he's speaking logic he's
seeing the reality of it but people are
they don't accept that because they are
coming from an emotional place and this
is well again you have to take a step
back and if someone is acting from an
emotional place
you're very easy to control
that's interesting like if I had a
conversate because I was very tempted to
go in like David Wood's show because he
just irritates me
if I asked him who did Jesus pray to he
can't tell the truth and answer it
honestly like it's so it's ridiculous
like forgive them Fatso so allegedly
Jesus impregnated Mary with himself God
impregnated Mary with himself to give
birth to himself to then pray to himself
to fulfill himself
um he then sacrificed himself to himself
to then turn back the kingdom that he
gave himself to himself to sit at the
right hand side of himself it's just
stupid and if I asked David wood who did
Jesus pray to and this is something I
want to give people and this is what I
have to sound logically myself and I
wrote it down and I can remember it of
my heart if you engage with someone
and they do the following four things
they try to subvert and I think the the
Trinity is subversion because it's
become he with no sin cast the first
stone I'm saved so I'm David wood I can
sit there and go you you you you but I'm
already saved because I accept Christ
the second one is lying lying's clear
who did Jesus pray to if you can't
answer that you're lying
shaming they try shaming Gaslight you
and go you're crazy you don't know and
then the other one is victimhood where
they act like a victim because if you're
the victim you can do no wrong and
there's a certain uh there's a a group
of people now who are Eternal victims
who do a lot of bad things but they
can't be questioned because they're
victims right
but like the the Trinity thing
um yeah it's not mentioned once in the
Bible it's just it's ridiculous
um
and I held to die on given the times as
theological debate over something so
tedious what you really want to be doing
now when the fourth biggest career
choice for women in the west is only
fans and you want to sit in your seat
they um
and just talk about how Jesus was God
and condemned people it's just stupid
it's just dumb it was the Council of
nicaea that came up with it it was a man
interpretation you know like the Council
of nicaea I think it was 60 to 40 came
up with the interpretation of Jesus's
God in my opinion oh I think
Christianity is nowadays is I think it's
low status men who want Power they want
influence and they want women
um and they can't get it this is why
they're always in my comment section
because if they were competent they
wouldn't be in my comment section and
they would be doing things like I don't
know building Christian social media but
they don't because they're incompetent
so if you're an incompetent male and you
want to attain power
hide behind the charge he you you're
saved you're already saved so just
condemn condemn condemn and if anyone
attacks you back you're the victim
because you're fighting for Christ you
know it's it's it's completely inverted
in my opinion and as well when you meet
Jesus God what you're saying in essence
is that no matter so God created the
laws of the world what to follow he
created man yet men with sin killed him
so if you're a young child and you see
okay so God who created these laws he
still didn't the man who didn't follow
them still had more power to kill him so
why would you follow the laws do you see
the trick it's a spell you go into a
Christian Church a young kid goes into a
Christian Church Jesus peace be upon Him
walked around with a whip he walked
around with a whip he wasn't a punk he
didn't you know what I mean he was a man
he was a he was a prophet
so every time you see Jesus now he's
just dead on a cross if Jesus got the
electric chair or he was hung would you
walk into a church and see him hanging
there no you know I mean it's stupid and
what does that do to a child's head when
you go into the Vatican the man who
killed Jesus with the the man who killed
him
can't remember his name it was something
spear or something long spear or
something you go into the Vatican you
went to the Vatican that guy's statue is
massive is ripped he's all strong so if
a cat goes in and he goes dad who's that
who's that ripped guy that everyone
thinks is so cool he's the guy that
killed God and then who's that guy on
the Cross covered in blood who's dead
and defeated or that's the guy who you
should live like he's God what does that
do to her kid's head you know okay no
false Idols is this is one of the
Christians David wood I'd be happy to
come on and discuss this if you'd like
if you're listening because you probably
are
no false not no false Idols um no graven
images there's no images of the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him but every
Church you go into Jesus who again says
in the Bible
no no graven images they've they've in
essence sexualized Jesus you go into a
church and he's ripped and he's there
with his long hair even though Jesus
said men shouldn't have long hair it's a
just contradiction contradiction
contradiction contradiction
won't talk about that you ask them who
did Jesus pray to they go I don't know I
don't think it's their thoughts in their
head like we said earlier I think it's
shatan you know I I think most
Christians wouldn't actually believe if
you told them that the first picture of
Jesus peace be upon Him supposedly was
the depiction
of Leonardo DiCaprio's not that not da
Vinci bro not DiCaprio
hey no no shots fired at Lino DiCaprio
buddy DiCaprio go for young women
yeah no but uh da Vinci it was uh his
gay lover
that this was the depiction is the
painting of his gay lover and here you
have like millions of people looking at
this picture of the gay lover and they
think that he is uh Jesus or they think
that he is God it's a stupid man it says
no Grieving images in the Bible so why
is Jesus why why do you go on Netflix
and you see the Chosen and some actors
know Jesus just stupid man they don't
listen
it's a funny one in my opinion you know
it doesn't make it well it does make
logical sense because if you're the
digital and you wanted to return you
would probably want people to think that
God could take the form of man you know
it would be quite convenient for our for
our uh a false Messiah you know because
these things don't make any sense
logically and again it's just like it's
not a hell I'd like to die on in these
types I think there's as guys we have
hierarchies of needs you know and things
that need to get done so for example if
you're if your house is being invaded
you're not gonna go paint a painting
you're going to deal with your house
being invaded so while all the things
are going on in the west is sitting in
mind this is for everyone watching this
who does it is sitting in my comment
section on the three Muslims comment
sections really the battle that you want
to engage in at this moment in time I
don't think it is but I know the reason
you do it is because you can't do
anything because you don't even follow
your own book
and that's why they don't have the
strength to stand up to things like the
LG TV or the usury user is outlawed in
the Bible it's the number one sin yet
the entire Financial system in America
is based on usury so if you don't have
the strength to defend yourself against
that why not just create something like
the Trinity so you can argue till
the cows come home because you can't do
anything else you know
yeah I mean with others being said man
it just kind of
brings everything into Clarity on that
the biggest challenge for dawa is to
bring people from this delusional
emotional state into a logical frame
because the moment someone can get into
this logical State they will see a
hundred percent that Islam is the truth
and when you see that Islam is the truth
once you see the truth you will see that
everything else is not the truth by
default right you can't have it you
can't have a hundred truths two thousand
truths one million truth no you have one
objective truth yeah and then when you
start to see the digitalis plant
you start to see that it's all about
division not Unity division because
divided we fall yes exactly together
together we rise divided we fall so if
you start to see that this is the plan
of the job if you start to see that then
you understand that every other thing
that's being presented that is not
logical that is not pointing to the
objective truth is by default false when
you have these things where it's like oh
every single religion is true are you
serious
if okay so you have a religion that's
saying that um there is no God
then you have a religion saying that God
is three and one
then you have a religion saying that we
are God
then you have a religion saying that no
there's thousands of gods then you have
a religion saying that no there's only
one God so which one is true if they're
all true it was a king James's truth
King James who wrote the Bible which is
now the main one that people buy was one
of the most sinful Kings in history and
he wrote a Bible and no one questioned
it right as King James God like you just
you know what they're blinded by their
sin and I'm glad you pointed that out
that divided uh divided we fall United
We Stand thing because this is why all
the propaganda because if you read the
Bible not the parts that Paul wrote
Because again like okay this is one for
the Christians David wood I'm happy to
come on
um Paul
met Jesus on the road to Damascus with
no Witnesses Paul was four foot six
which doesn't sound very
um good to me because uh men who lack in
departments try make up for another ones
and he was four foot six he met Jesus on
the road to Damascus as he was on the
road to Damascus he was actually going
to murder Christians and Jesus came to
him with no Witnesses after saying he
wouldn't come back and made him an
apostle even though Jesus said there
would be no Apostles no more Apostles
right and then he wrote 80 of the New
Testament he's the guy that brought in
the you're already saved Jesus died for
your sin Jesus died for me so I can
watch x videos that's not how it works
right
but if you actually follow the teachings
of Jesus right and you are uh a
Christian in that sense
there needs to be a Unity between and I
know I can attack the churchians I like
to make that distinction
um between Christian and churchian and I
just think there's a massive swaying
nowadays where people don't follow the
Jesus the teachings of Jesus peace be
upon him they just condemn people and
say they're saved
but the reason all this propaganda was
required to get a Christian country to
go bomb Afghanistan Iraq and Iran is
because you don't realize how similar
they are the Bible and and the Quran I
think they're very similar I just think
the Quran is the truth I don't think it
was written by man you know I don't
think I've had any man interpretation or
how dare you the word Bible was never
mentioned once in the Bible who wrote it
you can't name the person I think it was
wrong
and that's why the propaganda was
required you know they couldn't if if
the propaganda wasn't required that
would mean there would be a difference
in ideology I don't think there is to a
huge extent and that's why they required
all the propaganda to go to get
Christians to go bomb
um Muslim countries overseas you know
so so yeah I would say that
um and like you said with the Dao thing
and I've came to this realization as
well and I think this is something I
learned being in the west because I
always would scream at the top of my
lungs and I went nuts for a bit to be
fair because I just couldn't understand
why people didn't care
and then I realized you can't really
convince people to do anything and
there's a there's a stat that is and I
don't know the numbers exactly but it's
when people are presented data which
contradicts their current beliefs they
actually become more steadfast in their
beliefs which is why you can go to our
church here and just say who did Jesus
pray to and they get more and more into
it
so what you have to do is stick to your
Dean stand strong in the face of Haram
and bear the fruits of that life and if
you take for example the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him if he said
all the things he said but he didn't do
what he did I don't know how I'm trying
to get my point across I don't want to
be disrespectful but I can't think of a
better way to articulate this but if if
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
say he didn't follow anything he said
and he was just indulgent and he lived
like the average man in the west he was
Lost full degenerate would people have
listened to his message they wouldn't
have but because he was an example
he then became a leader and I always
make this distinction I never want to be
a leader I just want to be an example
but what happens is when you're so
strong with your dean and you're so
strong in the face of Haram and you
start to Bear the fruits of that and
you'll know this when guys quit things
that are bad for them like I always say
to guys when they come to me how do I
make money how do I have more energy how
do I stop procrastinating as if they can
just get those things I tell them stop
watching porn as soon as you do that
unlimited energy unlimited Focus
unlimited Drive
if you can stay strong in the face of
Haram and become the example for people
they will start following you if these
like that young guy like me like me
young people in the Wester are confused
who might be Christian but don't know
what to do if they look out and see
Muslim communities standing strong
having families being Halal not cocking
they're then going to follow you you
know they're then going to follow you so
that's my advice to people with regards
to dawah is um you can't really tell
people to do anything you can only
really in my opinion
um help them or Inspire them and that's
how I think the the battle for the next
however long I think that's how it's
going to operate in my opinion I could
be wrong but that's how I perceive it
yeah yeah you live by example and then
you only speak when they come to you
asking you a question exactly yeah
exactly because if if you just want to
like go at it with them well then it's
just the ego you know they're not going
to accept it their their emotion is
basically blinding them and this is why
I just want to give you a fair warning
with this whole David wood apostate
prophet and other stuff man they're not
worth yeah I agree or the day because
bro it's like these people these people
they've already been dismantled by
people of knowledge and once they've
been dismantled by people are not just
like okay that's it like it's done
what's done it's done so anything else
they're bringing to the table now it's
really
it's feeble yeah it's not something that
can be backed and then what do they try
to do they try to get at people who uh
maybe don't have that much knowledge
maybe are just fresh onto the dean and
it's all ego it's all ego if you were to
strip them away from the money that
they're getting from the the patreon
supporters or from the the YouTube views
and stuff like this
would they still be doing what they're
doing no not a chance they're like
vampires in my opinion and I made this
this distinction earlier with the fact
that I'm not I'm not attacking anyone in
specific but it's a pattern I recognized
as their low status men who want power
but aren't capable of attaining it so
they hide behind we're already saved
condemned condemned condemn
and I think they're vampires and the
only way they can extract from you is
through your attention so what would be
more fruitful me going on his show and
asking him who did Jesus pray to who did
Jesus pray to oh how dare you how dare
you you don't know right that's a waste
of my time I'm gonna be annoyed at the
end of it I could have spent that time
doing something
so I was I had a thought there I can't
remember what it was bro and ultimately
whatever you say on the video that you
do with him he's going to twist it he's
going to twist it and make it seem as
though you were the stupid one and you
didn't know what you were talking about
yeah that's what I said earlier that
that checklist of things shame they
always try Gaslight you and they'll
shame you and try and make you look
crazy this is why I don't look at
comment sections anymore
so my I I when I first started uploading
and I would say my ratio of positive to
negative comments is about
99.7 something right but
um and it's always ironic because all
the guys in my comment sections
they're Anonymous so I'll be like
Muhammad and he'll be like oh great
video man I was struggling with this
I've had guys message me saying they've
took a shahada because of me and the um
the what I've said brought light to the
things that they were confused about and
it'll be like you know a Muslim name
Muslim name Muslim name and then it will
just be like James and he'll be like you
sir you're going to hell you're evil and
I'm like what are you doing right but I
realized as well with regards to like if
you were to go into David wood stream
it's just a waste of time and what is
the motivation behind that well in my
opinion it would be vanity on my part
because I'd want to school
and this is why I've got a point to make
here it might take a while to get to it
but the reason I don't look at comment
sections anymore is because
and like I was saying earlier with the
they have to make you do it to yourself
if I go through my comment sections and
I'm enjoying all the praise I get and
obviously it's not my motivation but of
course when people are complimenting you
you like it so if I go through my
comments and people are being like great
video great video great video and then I
see you're going to hell you're yeah and
now I'm annoyed and it gets in my head
how dare you the Trinity right that
annoys me
but how did it get to me because I
wanted the praise and I think Pride
and
praise and fear are just two wings of
the same bird and they're Illusions it
doesn't whether someone likes me or they
don't agree with me doesn't change who
we are as people and it's like two wings
of the same Bird that's flying in a
direction which is taking you off the
path you know so with regards to arguing
with people about dumb stuff there is no
point you will know them by their fruits
if you really believe what you think and
think they're wrong live your life the
way that you would argue it let them
live the life that they would argue and
see who's in a better position in 10 20
years time that's the way to go in my
opinion
bro this reminds me of the one verse in
the Quran where
uh Allah is talking about the people I'm
not going to say the name but Allah's
talking about the people who are
claiming certain things
and then Allah
upon him to basically tell them to wish
for death
if what they say is true but that they
will never wish for death because they
know that what they're saying it's it's
not real
yeah 100 that's a big distinction uh
that has changed for me recently
as um I uh it's not unlike and people
called me I posted this on my Instagram
because I do have a tendency just this
young guy who isn't castrated to get you
get aggressive at things like when
things annoy you you know what I mean
and I posted something the other day and
I took it down quickly and it was along
the lines of if I got my hands on like
the CEO of pornhub or something right
and I think that makes logical sense
molesting children and turning your
daughters into to to horse through human
trafficking I think that makes logical
sense
um
but the Vengeance isn't mine all I could
do is hurt the Flesh and that isn't what
matters and before anyone goes all
psycho psycho cycle you've been
propagandized to think that through
events I'm not going to mention because
I don't want to get you banned what's
more crazy a young male who doesn't like
children being molested getting his
hands on someone who does it and not
taking kindly to it or signing up for
the US military to go bomb people and
shoot people in farms you don't know
overseas so you can get employment you
know people that people don't realize
how programmed they are man like they
don't realize it but the distinction
I've made is this thing these things are
not in my hands it's all like like you
said what what's worse for them being
being hurt physically in this world or
waiting till Allah sees them again in
the Hereafter and that's a big
distinction that's changed for me
because obviously as a young guy you see
all this and you're like go to war go to
war and just burn all ground but it's
not in your hands and that that's
liberating in my opinion you know well
now that I'm thinking about this
literally when you take a step back from
everything like we were talking about
you get away from the programming and
when you get away from all the
programming your mind starts to become a
very clear and the truth becomes evident
and you start to be
I want to say guided but I didn't say I
can't say that because a lot of guys who
he was and some people just
unfortunately they're not going to be
guided not because God doesn't want to
guide them because well it's it's their
own doing it's by their own hands
but I remember when I did the dopamine
detox you know long story short I cut
everything out so all the programming
was completely wiped away and I remember
feeling that pool to read the Quran and
not understanding why I felt that pool
and then doing the same thing like
several months later having the same
exact feeling ended up reading the Quran
and it's like
instantly you just instantly clicked and
it all made sense
yeah big time you know I mean this is I
say this to people a lot and I'm going
to give more advice because I don't know
um this is all my that goes on in my
head during the day but like you said
there if so
because I got a lot of messages from
guys asking about things like
proactivity and money and stuff right
we do not exist in a vacuum or NASA how
dare you the Trinity we don't exist in a
vacuum so an hour has to be full of
something an hour can't be empty right
so a minute always has to be full of
something we don't exist in a vacuum if
you want to add things like reading the
Quran reading working building a
business creating ideas have doing
things that are fruitful you can't just
cram more into that hour you first have
to take out the poison which is filling
it the illusions that are filling it
um so you have to if you want to fill a
bucket with water you can't just pour
water in when it's already full you have
to take it out
and if you try and just actively do
things like read the Quran you're it's
almost like you're pulling against
resistance and I can prove this because
if you took a caveman for like four I
don't know 10 000 years ago and said you
with your infected ankle is going to die
in a month chasing a saber-toothed tiger
who hasn't eaten in a week you can sit
in a nice warm air-conditioned room with
nice clothes and read a book it would go
right the reason you find it hard is not
because it is hard it's because of the
resistance to the life that you actually
live on the uh your average Lifestyle
the reason you find things like reading
the Quran difficult and focusing hard is
not because it's hard in and of itself
it's because your typical minute and
your typical hour is already full of
things which are pulling at that it's
creating resistance so how are you going
to focus on things that are fruitful and
positive if at the back of your mind you
could get the same dopamine through
tiktok for free if you first want if you
want to apply the best form of attack is
defense if you want to add new fruitful
things
into your life you first have to take
out the Haram and that's probably the
the main teaching point with Islam and
why I love it so much is because it
stops that you know like you can't
here's one here's one I could I can
prove again
um I keep bringing this up because I
know you know about it as well
um a lot of it's just a physical
response so if you look at the the
pornography side of things right
you can watch pornography and you can
get erectile dysfunction you can then
want to go and have a family with your
wife but you physically can't get an
erection because you have a physical
response to the Haram in your life if
you want to go have a family with a
woman you can't just make it happen
there has to be a sacrifice the word
sacrifice
originates from the word the two words
sacrifaka in Latin and the word
sacrifice the word sacrifice
originations were to give unto God to
receive again so if you want good things
to come into your life you can't just
make them happen something has to go
first if you know what I'm if you know
what I mean you get where I'm going from
it's interesting yeah that's interesting
though
that's very interesting
like if you want to focus like I can sit
in my chair and work for 14 hours a day
it's not because I have willpower and I
just want it as a marketing ploy to get
people to buy your courses it's disrupt
injury click shame you you're a failure
you need to buy my courses solve your
problem I can do this because my head
isn't full of song lyrics I don't have
my phone in my room and I don't over
stimulate my brain with Haram things so
I can just do it if I tried to do that
while I was still engaging in this sort
of stuff I wouldn't be able to
so the best form of attack is defense
and if you want to add new things to
your life you first have to give up the
Haram sacrifice give unto God to receive
again you know
okay and Allah says in the Quran if you
give something up for actually I don't
think it's on the ground I think this is
where if you give something up for the
sake of Allah and then Allah will
replace it with something for better
yeah
yeah and it reminds me of this thing I
realized a long time ago where
if you're trying to be more mindful if
you're trying to be more present
it all starts in the little moments and
you like if if you are let's say you're
on I don't know YouTube
and then I don't know where you started
scrolling in your mind is in school and
you're mindlessly consuming like what
makes you think that an hour from now
two hours from now you're gonna be
mindful and you're gonna be present
in that moment you will not
yeah 100 I'm gonna do something right
and I want someone to verify this in the
chat I'm going to do maths right I think
off the top of my head this is how I
look at the world is that you shouldn't
see things as minor indulgences you
should see them as your personality and
if you all love it you're that type of
person so I don't tolerate Tick Tock
because where do you draw the line an
hour or two hours three hours it's
either there it's not
if you look at the world as as a day is
actually your entire life because it's a
cyclical pattern and I think this is the
I think the number is close and I want
someone to verify this in the chat if
you take an hour
of your day
and times it by 70 across 70 years
if I get this right right
um I think it would I think it's
something it would be something like 25
220 or something hours so when you
actually spend an hour on Tick Tock a
day you're actually wasting over the
course of your life because if you allow
it you allow it all the time you're
actually allowing 25 200 hours to go to
waste so don't see things as a a one-off
see them as what you just are you know
can someone verify that's the correct
number because if it is there you go
you'll know them by their fruits but
yeah look at it as a as a habit it's
your personality are you the type of
person who um
who allows it you know
but um again
2200 and
2550 hours I was close right see
um but yeah don't see it as a one-off
seat as are you the type of person who
allows it it's your personality it's
your character either a lower or you
don't draw a line in the sand because
when you waste an hour you're actually
wasting thousands over the course of
your life so so yeah
2550.
200 off
is my connection gone
yours bro yeah oh no yeah yeah there's
no connection
there we go we got him
yeah I can hear you now
how many days is it
how many days would that be I have no
idea
uh
you just divided by 24 does someone have
the actual number like pulled up on the
phone or something
well it's 25 550 hours as people are
saying in the chat and if you divide
that by 24. about a thousand days bro
yeah
yeah the ten thousand dollar rule ten
thousand dollar rule if you you become a
master at something in ten thousand
hours and this is how I get so much done
so over the past few weeks I'm I'm
creating a Muslim version of the war
room I'm creating my own social media
I'm creating a course like user doing on
how to quit Xenon pornography I'm doing
another one I'm writing a book I'm doing
all this stuff and it's because if you
allow an hour of your day to go to waste
you your legs so much gone so if you
look at the 10 000 hour rule which is
how you become world class at something
through ten thousand hours of repetition
you could have become in that time you
spend on Tech talk over the course of
your life for an hour you could have
become a world-class piano player a
world-class
I don't know musician um athlete and you
could have become a semi-world class
writer you know look at it that way in
my opinion so so yeah 1 6004 days yeah
hmm
so yeah it's a it's an interesting one
and but again why are these things free
these things are free because they want
you doing that you know
in my opinion
that's very crazy
man
has been very real
it's been very real wrong yeah circus we
gotta have you back bro for part two
maybe part three bro this is the second
time there's no there's no way we can
get everything in one stream but look no
no no I thought um like isn't part three
just part one what part is the Holy
Ghost you know what I mean you know what
I'm saying yeah we'll definitely come
back on it's uh it's been great and I
think next time I come home we can talk
about the um the positive side of things
but I think with the audience you guys
have
I think it had to be more of not doing
glim one because again no one can make
you do these things but certain things
had to be addressed
um but next to my mom we can we can talk
about more positive things but I think
uh it's been great nevertheless you know
mashallah
I do I think the last thing yeah I do
well I think we both got one question
all right we both we got one pass each
yeah go for him my last question for you
today bro Michael is gonna be
what would this is a Michael or Matthew
correct me it's a Matthew I love you
okay so Matthew my last question for you
today would be
what was your favorite verse of the
either Quran or favorite Hadith or
something about Islam that stuck out
until today it's one of your favorite
things about being a Muslim I'll give
you a Hadith and I'm gonna paraphrase it
and not paraphrase it but the story and
the one I liked a lot and it resonated a
lot with me was the story when the
Mongols came into Baghdad you know I'm
on a boat
um with the Mongols conquered Baghdad
when the Islamic empire had become
remarkably rich and and I I say this a
lot and I'll say it again that I don't
think so now the idea of success is
material you want to become a
millionaire you want the girls Etc and I
always say the game never changes
because I'm already mentally preparing
for this a diagram goes off it's a good
chance I could end up with a nine figure
net worth
but nothing changes so if you're uh I'll
get back to my point about the the
Hadith because it ties into this if
you're a
if you're a lonely guy and you have
impulses of lust you have impulses of
sloth you have impulses of of bad people
around you when you're a loser guy low
status your lustful Temptations will be
Instagram thoughts and pornography your
bad environment
will be
um friends who just want to go drinking
and take drugs losers
your sloth would be scrolling Tech talk
all day now say you sacrificed them and
you became a wealthy man
the the Temptation doesn't go away
shatan doesn't leave you alone he just
changes face
and um
what would occur then is the loss would
go from pornography addiction and it
would go to Haram women on a Dubai
billionaires boat and if you don't get
that in check you end up like Jeff Bezos
or something they're bad friends around
you go from
losers you want to medicate your pain
with by taking drugs and drinking and it
goes to
um people doing mountains of snow on or
at some rich place because you feel
important and then the sloth goes from
Tick Tock it goes to you want to drive
your supercars around and flex and you
put your business on the side and it
crumbles
so nothing changes and if you look at
the story of when the Mongols conquered
Baghdad once the Islamic empire become
remarkably Rich it was said I believe
that one Mongolian woman could go into a
house of 50 Muslim men and take them all
out because he'd become so rich and lazy
and sedated you know and so that Rings a
lot and you can see that in the west no
what do you think's happening these big
Empires become so rich and indulgent
that they can't defend themselves from
anything how do you think the LG TV
thinks conquered everywhere it's the
same thing that happened in that and my
favorite verse and I'm going to
paraphrase this but it made a lot of
sense and I want to make a point about
this as well and I'm going to paraphrase
it but it's along the lines of and I was
speaking to people about this a lot
because this is a big topic I know I get
loads of messages about this and it was
um for wicked women for wicked men there
will be wicked women and for righteous
men there will be righteous woman and
there's a lot of fear p-o-r-n
oh there are nowadays that all women are
promiscuous they're all thoughts again
who's like the social media thing I
talked about yeah
you know I mean it's just dumb but like
I said it's not organic like I said
about the social media you can create
this false culture and but there are
Halal women out there Wicked manner for
Wicked Woman and guys will say this all
the time and I realize this as well and
this is why this verse made so much
sense to me these guys in the west
complain about promiscuous women you
find them in a nightclub on Instagram
righteous women aren't going to be
posting stuff on Instagram and then
nightclubs that you'll get with a woman
in a nightclub sleep with her one night
and then six months down the line you
find out she cheated on you in a
nightclub righteous women of a righteous
men Wicked Woman or for Wicked man so
that's my two I I love reading the story
about the the Mongols and Baghdad
because that um Rings true nowadays that
when you become wealthy the shatan
doesn't go away just changes the face
he'll attack your pride he'll attack you
through fornication he'll attack you
through it nothing goes away you know I
think in that Hadith it was uh one of
the Mongols said something along the
lines of why are you eating with a
golden plate you could have had 50 men
with Spears at your door but what
happens they look at America you get so
wealthy that you become so incapable of
doing anything and you get conquered
instantly it's like met men with empty
stomach and empty stomachs and full
balls conquer men with empty balls and
full stomachs you know so when when you
do inherit success don't put the dean to
the side because nothing actually
changes you know
um abundance is actually the biggest
test for a man yeah I think it was um
one of the hadees
it was uh by um
regular one
I think that's correct way to say I'm
not sure
for the correction
and he said that
I don't feel for you
um Defenders of like women or anything
like this but what I fear for you is
that the doors to this Dunya are opened
yeah and you have everything that you
could have ever dreamed of yeah because
it truly is when you have abundance
that's the biggest test and Allah says
it many many times in the Quran he gives
the example of the people who are out at
Sea they're in a boat and their ship is
about to sink and they're they're
basically begging to Allah to save them
to get them out of this alive and that
they would worship Him and only
basically the worship and Associate no
one with them in Partners but then the
moment they get to see then they start
associating pointers and the way that
they associate Partners it's not that oh
you know we we came to land because of
uh
we lost them boys they lost just like
that
it's the Holy Spirit
man guys bear with the technical
difficulties Anna's not at home right
now he is currently in America
there's a little bit of a
lack of his setup and his current Wi-Fi
America does that to you bro
oh yeah back time back time that's the
thing I've been um
I've been um
striked twice under 20K that was just
that I know it's obviously not that but
um they'll get you if they want to get
you you know what I mean
if someone just said his Lord Bears heat
on too high I'm sunburned is what it is
never get sunny out in Scotland and when
it doesn't turn into a tomato so that's
all it is that's why I look red
oh
I think that's in someone else where do
you think you can find Halal partners
um they'll find you exactly they'll find
you and if they are someone you can find
um anyone can find them so I'm probably
going to get married next year Dan's
working hard on this one bro
um
says well the Matrix is attacking
but with regards to what
um you just said yeah you don't find
them they find you and I'm not being
funny uh so I'm like a like a as an
arrogant saying this but um if you're
not
a completely useless idiot nowadays
there's a massive surplus of good woman
to good men like if you look at the
average male nowadays they're
incompetent yeah and so if you just do
things that are good you know like I If
you do things are good they'll find you
like the woman that I'm probably going
to marry next year the way she found me
was she me she she she had an Instagram
with like 10 followers
and then message me and because I'm not
a lustful guy I actually replied to her
going thank you brother we will win this
war don't check their accounts right and
then before you know it it's like you
found a Halal woman who's on your side
you're not gonna find those girls in a
nightclub you're not gonna find them on
Instagram you know when they are there
wicked women are for Wicked man if
you're a lustful guy you'll just attract
the same they are out there so you
better hurry up before I get them are we
are we invited to the knicker bro
yeah 100 everyone's invited man no no no
no no bro just just keep it to yourself
keep it to you and the lady and just
family bro yeah big time Big Time
um but yeah you're not gonna find those
girls on um
on Tinder or even Muzz match something
like that if they're advert if there are
they're posting themselves they're
advertising themselves you know what I
mean I mean they means they have male
attention on a pedestal and that's not
mgto it's just is what it is you know I
mean so they'll find you and the way you
get them to find you is you go do things
you don't sit and watch red pill dark
videos about how all women are demons
right go do something
yeah and let's let's put a disclaimer on
there that people don't go and do this
just for the sake of getting a woman
like if you're gonna develop yourself if
you're gonna have purpose you're gonna
do something
yeah you know like don't don't do it
just so you can get a lot of team do it
because you know you're trying to
actually do Allah's work here you're
trying to do your part before your time
inspires you 100
. oh he's going again Matrix has
attacked 2.0 his major is attacking it's
David wood David Woods been hired by
the big boys but I'll take what you said
and wrong with that
um
um as I was saying
uh he was saying don't do it for a woman
and I can verify that because like I
don't check their accounts when they
message me so the woman that I'm
probably going to marry when she message
me because I don't look because I don't
care because I'm not doing it for that I
said thank you brother we will win the
war inshallah and she's like no I'm
actually a girl so if you don't do it
for a woman they're just a um
I don't know I can't explain it I think
uh yeah
you just you're just on the path towards
attaining the love and pleasure of Allah
there's no the question is is fallible
in and of itself where do you find good
women it's like bro you could be in the
perfect places where you would seemingly
find a Halal musama that's on point but
then if Allah doesn't will you're not
going to get it if you're just wasting
your life being degenerate you're living
a life of you know doing Allah's work
like we're talking about but then you're
in the most inopportune you know place
where you don't expect anyone to be just
like this brother was talking about
getting a DM like that it's like it's
almost miraculous not a coincidence but
it occurs in a way where you know it's
from Allah yeah big time man and me and
her were actually talking about that
because I know I said earlier about um
whose thoughts are in your head so when
you um when you drink alcohol thoughts
come in your head that might not be your
own but when you so I'm not kidding
right on how dare you I know the
churches won't be able to relate to this
right because you're all Geeks
what I was saying was
um like I was saying earlier about how
they can put thoughts in your head if
you engage in Haram it's like shatan
gets controlling put thoughts in your
head
and um what happens when you give up
Haram for Halal I think
um you know Allah or the Angels so to
say might start putting thoughts in your
head because the way that me and her
were talking about this the way that we
interacted after like the whole thank
you brother thing
whose thoughts are in the whose thoughts
are in whose head you know who decides
to to do these things so I think there
is a degree of divine intervention and
but yeah like is that because I'm any
better than anyone no I don't think so I
think it's because I went from unlimited
Haram woman prior to Islam and overnight
gave them all up and then you give me
you make that sacrifice for the greater
good and you get rewarded with something
good you know so this whole this whole
hopelessness
um of all women are promiscuous and
mgtow it's just marketing it's not real
there are good women out there you just
have to look for them no don't look for
them go do things and they'll go look
for you
so that's that
closer we get to Allah
Global rewarders and ways that we've
never done
what do you say sorry I said Dunya is
going to be at your feet yeah big time
Allah says that
if you chase the Dunya then you will
have neither the Akira or the Dunya but
if you chase the Akira then you have
both Akira and the Dunya yeah it makes
sense
Miss talk sounds yeah 100
so um so yeah did you have a question on
hell
yeah man I was gonna ask you how are you
dealing with the tattoos how are the
Muslim brothers and sisters treating you
with that
so I would say
um
it's an interesting one this oh we
didn't even cover Sharia law today right
which like I would have nikal with
Sharia law easy I love Sharia law right
this is my favorite thing and the good
distinction about Sharia and this is I'm
going to Tyler some of the tattoos is
the the public versus private where if
you're LG TV if you're LG TV and you do
that in your own closed doors that's
between you and Allah if you try to take
that publicly and display it to people
you know
and with the tattoos thing when I go to
a mosque I am I put a turtleneck on and
I try to cover them because I don't want
you know because like I said if you're
an example you typically will become a
leader and people will want to be like
you and I don't want young kids to hear
what I'm saying
and see tattoos on my hands and neck and
stuff so I cover them when I'm public
and if I go into a mosque sorry
um in the future I'm probably going to
get the ones that can't be concealed
taken off like the neck the hand but a
part of me kind of and it's not ill
intented it's not really through vanity
but the reason I would keep the ones
that could be concealed is that I I
think that if there's a young guy like
me out there
who is thinking of Islam but he's not
sure if he'll be accepted a part of me
does kind of think if I have some that
still remain you'll be like oh yeah well
if he was accepted to all that but as
for in public I conceal them when I go
to a mosque because I don't want to uh
set a bad example and people can verify
this when I took my shahada I was
sweating
buckets because I had this thick
turtleneck that was covering and
everything so but that's my opinion on
that yeah man I didn't hear most of it
bro my thing has been tripping
dance really really trying hard over
here no I was just saying um when I go
to a mosque and stuff I cover them up
because I don't yeah I'm probably
displaying them um but in primers right
you know
um
bro I was gonna tell you from my own
experience and this is very uh
Politically Incorrect so I was like
maybe Islam goes because
uh this is not I can't give you sources
for this is just from my own experience
so please you know take it as you will
but the way I see is that there's a time
and place for everything when you go to
the Masjid you want to cover up why
because it's going to be little kids
it's going to be little Muslims and you
don't want to set the example for them
when they look and they're like oh well
if tattooing is Haram then why does he
get to have tattoos make them want to do
the sins but then there's also a
situation where you're walking in public
and someone sees you like let's say you
are with your wife but let's see you
again you're walking and your wife is a
hijab and she's covered up but you have
your tattoo showing and someone stops
you because they're so curious like yo
this this guy has tattoos and he's with
this woman who's clearly a Muslim
because she has the hijab I'm just
confused like what is this like what's
going on so it opens up a doorway for
dawa that otherwise would not have been
there yeah so I I in my personal opinion
I do feel there is a time and place for
everything so long as you have your
intention in the correct place and
you're using it in the right and the
right purpose okay yeah 100 so I'll
probably get the ones on my neck because
like the hand and the neck I've got to
be honest with you
um it's just to try and attract women
like the hand and the neck ones right
I'm not gonna lie I'm not gonna beat
around the bush you're you're trying to
find a girlfriend but they're all an
only fans so you're like if I get
tattoos like Machine Gun Kelly or
something that you know I mean it's all
it was already shallow
um so the ones I can't conceal I'm
probably gonna get rid of
I think because like I said it's just
more convenient
um
but yeah I don't mind having some
because like I said earlier if there's a
guy like me who's considering Islam but
he's not sure if he's bigger enough if
he sees that I still have somebody who
he knows that he'll be accepted as well
then I think that can help with dower
I'll get around to it I'll get around to
it eventually
for you just know that you're not
obligated to do so because Allah already
you know he forgive us so yeah I'm glad
I didn't get any on my face because I
think if I had some on my face and then
the Lord
think that I want to give people the gel
Vibes you know bro you know another now
that you see that there's actually this
one brother on YouTube I think is uh Evo
Evo or something he's actually trying to
get the tattoos on his face removed so
if people are watching and they want to
help that brother out I believe he was
um trying to do like a little fundraiser
to be able to get that I think that'd be
a beautiful thing to help my brother in
the slam to get rid of those tattoos if
you want yeah man big time
um and I think he mentioned it as well
as he was fed up or looking like Little
Joe
and I'm glad I never got any on my face
because it would have looked quite bad
eh but but yeah
100 bro
well bro it has been truly blessed to
everyone
I'm looking forward to the next time
that we're all together inshallah we'll
have Rami as well
and um I think you only have rami's
contact
but if you want or if you have fire
because I think you you message him on
Instagram yeah we can make a group chat
let's make a group chat on like actual
messages because I don't really like
spending too much time on social media
which is weird because I'm a influencer
but oh I'm the same man I don't like it
at all I don't like it at all
um we'll do a WhatsApp or something
we'll get something sorted out and next
time next time I'm on we can talk about
more positive things but I just think
there's things I had to bring to
people's attention
today you know that was great it's gonna
get ugly before it gets pretty guys for
sure I I don't know but does it because
I think your internal world is all that
matters I think
God okay give me a minute to say
something if you take four men right and
you you'll know I'm gonna use the same
one I've been using all day right is it
four men you put one on cocaine one on
alcohol one's a porn addict and one's
hungover and you tell them go speak in
front of a thousand people and go ask a
woman to be your wife
the the cocaine Alex gonna be like yeah
go go go go go the porn addict's gonna
is ah swore out of bed with someone
I shouldn't swear this stream off God's
sake oh he doesn't say this he's in the
chat as well how to bet have I swore
once today I have to drop my motorbike
off at this house for a month go right
to the end and he's in the chat
um but they're all going to have
different perceptions of the challenge
it's like they project what's on the
side oh I think the Matrix isn't real I
think the Matrix is inside but then say
for example you took four Halal men
guys who are retaining whose heads
aren't full of song lyrics you aren't
distracted they're going to be excited
they're going to be like go go go go go
so things will only get bad if you
choose for it to get bad and I I heard a
quote the other day and it was Halal as
Halal Lumar if nobody is doing it and
Haram is Haram no matter if everybody is
doing it and things will only get bad if
you choose to it doesn't matter how many
people are doing bad things no one can
force you to do anything you can stand
this is what I want to do with my
platform as I want to um show people
even in the what what seems to be the
darkest time that you can still have a
a Heavenly sort of life because you can
and it's all done to the choices you
make no one else can make you do it
doesn't matter if everybody's engaging
in Haram if you don't
you will um you'll be fine
I don't mind it either because like if
things keep getting bad it just means
like competition gets less and less or
something you know
um so there's always there's an equal
and opposite reaction to things so don't
worry about it
um things only get bad if you choose to
it doesn't matter how bad the world
around you get so if you keep your
internal World pure you'll be fine you
know
that's true and I think he's back let's
see here we go right on time bro
man The Matrix is attacked five times
today guys smash that like button what
are we doing for y'all and uh oh no bro
give a closing door if you want
I like Hello mothers
I don't know the Arabic yet so I'm not
gonna uh say it